hello everybody welcome to
today's licensing board meeting um just
a bit of housekeeping to start with
um fire alarm procedures um if the fire
alarm is activated please take the
stairs down to the reception area and
out the building to the green in hawley
square
which is the assembly point please do
not use the lifts
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
council
offices filming and i would advise that
filming takes
my if your move takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured
i urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if they are children
present
does anyone intend filming or absent
if yes any member of the public who
objects to the possibility of being
filmed i wish to take this opportunity
to leave meeting
any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following exclusion of the
present public from the meeting
mobile phones would everyone present
please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls
in this room whilst the meeting is in
progress
um agenda item one apologies for absence
are there any apologies for absence
counsel howard councillor huxley
councillor huxley huxley thank you
agenda mice number two declaration of
interest
are there any declarations of interest
no
agenda item three minutes the last
meeting
police can have a member proposed in a
second that the minutes of the licensing
board meeting held on the 15th of june
2021
be approved and signed by the chairman
do members agree
so we need to propose that councillor
scoby
has given his apologies and um and he
was also present
okay and sorry a second council wing
thank you and members agree
um agenda item four minutes of the
licensing subcommittee
meeting since the last meeting of the
board please can i remember propose and
second that the minutes of the licensing
subcommittee meetings
that are included on the agenda be
approved and signed by the chairman
um councillor potts
and secondary councillor wing um do
members agree
thank you agendum item five
exclusion of public and press please can
i have a member proposing second that
the public and press be excluded from
the meeting for gender item six
as it contains exempt information as
defined in paragraph seven
or part one of the schedule 12 a of the
local government acts 1972 as amended
can i have a proposal counselor
i'm sure